Okay, can you hear me? Yes. All right. So I finally got my glute meter, my glucose meter and I started poking my finger and I finally get that down to understand how to get some sort of a consistent reading.
Why do you say 70 is kind of the target to set as a goal?
Well, there's been a lot of practitioners that take care of cancer patients that, you know, you've read things about, you know, okay.
So let's take a step back. Why are we trying to get blood glucose levels down to the first place? Well, because, you know, every cell,
they're first, you make energy for a cell, primarily through glycolysis, meaning you're breaking down glucose.
And cells also break down fatty acids to make energy through the fatty acid cycle, but the number one way to make energy for a cell and a cancer cell the same is you're breaking down glucose through glycolysis.
So you could say the number one fuel source for cancer is glucose. So now it's, it's even worse if you have HIF, what Agenes, then you're even more prone to fuel cancer that way because through the Warburg effect, we'll get into that.
I have some videos on that. So it makes sense to try to get glucose levels down. So everybody, everybody's got to go on a low sugar diet, low glycemic index diet, you know, you're trying to get your blood glucose levels down.
Now, you've also seen books that were written about every cancer patient should be on a ketogenic diet.
Well, first of all, that's not completely true because a ketogenic diet in itself can have other problematic effects because some people's cancer can be fed off of a methionine and a ketogenic diet is going to be extremely high in methionine.
And typically a ketogenic diet is going to also be high in dairy unless you're going on a dairy-free ketogenic diet, which is much more difficult.
And thirdly, really being on a ketogenic diet, try to get your body into ketosis, which gets your glucose levels down into the 60s, is extremely difficult.
And if you're over 30, it's really, it's almost impossible for most people to be honest.
Unless you're like this fitness guru that all you do is work out every day and you're 55 years old and you have the body like some movie star.
But that's not everybody, most people, okay?
So it's very difficult to get into ketosis.
So putting that pressure on a cancer patient I don't think is fair.
And it also, I'm sorry, but it takes all the joy out of your life because you can't have any social interaction with anybody over food anymore because you're on a ketogenic diet.
So, but you can be on a keto-like diet and still have good social interaction.
You can still live with your grandkids and have family functions and you're just not eating any sugar or you're staying away from high glycemic foods.
Kind of like a diabetic person should, right?
And it's been shown.
I mean, the guy who wrote the book about everybody of your cancer patient to be on a ketogenic diet isn't even a clinician.
He's a scientist looking at data, but he never treated one patient. He didn't treat patients.
I've had interaction with a lot of clinicians doing this.
And in my experience over 30 years of doing this is you could have just as good of results with shutting down the field source of cancer, just cutting way back on sugar and be on a keto-like diet.
I just named him as a keto-like diet years, years ago.
So, you're not trying to put yourself into ketosis.
You're just trying to get your glucose levels down.
And there's other data out there that if a cancer patient just gets their glucose levels into the 70s, which is very difficult in itself.
So, I'll talk about that.
They really have the exact same benefits as if they got into ketosis.
So, that being said, it's getting a glucometer can be beneficial because it can be a guide in to keep us on the straight narrow on our diet.
Because get a glucometer, test my blood glucose in the morning at a 10-hour fast and it's 105.
Well, you're already in syndrome X. You shouldn't be over 100. Nobody.
So, you're already way too high, even if you didn't have cancer.
So, that gives you some incentive, okay, I need to clean up my diet.
And pretty much everybody, unless they already have going into their cancer, they already have severe syndrome X and or worse, they already have diabetes.
It was never diagnosed. I've had people like that, so their fasting blood glucose is 155.
You know, they do everything, they can't get it there. They already have diabetes. They didn't even know it.
So, but let's say let's go back to our average person 105.
Now you're starting to clean up your diet and you're getting it down, or I could get it down to 90.
And it's just can't get it down. I had it at 88 one day and it was 93 the next day.
There's a lot of people, depending on what your age is, even if your diet was perfect, you're never getting any lower than it.
And again, that same person, even if they want a complete ketogenic diet, they're never getting the ketosis.
Because getting those blood glucose levels down is not solely dietary.
So, how's that? How could my blood glucose level still be 90?
When I don't eat any carbs whatsoever, I've been so good.
I don't eat any carbs whatsoever, it's still 90 in the morning.
Well, because your body has another process called gluconeogenesis, that means you make glucose.
So, your body makes glucose. Why is that? Because glucose isn't the preferred fuel for every cell.
So, your body makes glucose. Glucose is the preferred fuel for your brain.
So, in the middle of the night, you're not eating anything. You're on a fast.
Because you haven't eaten since, you know, seven o'clock the last night.
And it's now two o'clock in the morning, you've been on a six hour fast so far.
And your brain needs glucose because your brain never sleeps.
Your muscles don't need glucose. They're not even doing anything. You're just laying there in bed.
But your brain needs glucose because your brain never sleeps.
Your brain is always functioning. You're always firing neurons.
So, you actually release a hormone that stimulates your adrenals to release cortisol in the middle of the night
for the sole purpose of you breaking down glycogen stores in the liver to supply glucose
to keep your blood glucose levels from crashing so it feeds your brain in the middle of the night.
So, you have two main processes. I should say three main processes for your glucose levels.
Dietary glucose, number one, gluconeogenesis.
You're breaking down muscle to make glucose and break down of glycogen stores,
which glycogen is multiple glucose molecules put together in a giant molecule called glycogen that's stored in your liver for when you're fasting.
So, that's even overnight fasting.
So, your body is creating glucose, is storing glucose for the use of your muscles, for the use of your brain,
and unfortunately for the use of any cell that is calling for which cancer cells are highly metabolic and they're calling for glucose.
So, you can't get your glucose level too low.
If your glucose levels go too low, you'll go into coma because your brain shuts down.
So, if you could get your, in the perfect world, if you could get your glucose level into the 70s, not 70, but in the 70s,
you'd basically be functioning from a cancer standpoint is literally the same as if you're going to do it a ketogenic diet.
So, side note, ketogenic diet, you're getting your glucose level in the 50s and 60s, and you don't have enough glucose to burn,
so you start burning ketone, ketone bodies.
You don't need to do that for most cancers.
I mean, for brain cancer, glioblastoma, I would work even harder getting that down.
But if you're 50 years old and a glioblastoma, you're still not getting that ketosis.
So, try to get your glucose levels down as best you can.
Now, again, the problem is, depending on what age you are, depending on how damaged your cell membranes are and stuff,
there are some people you could literally go on a ketogenic diet and be religious about it and you never budge.
You'll never get into ketosis just because you just have too much damage of cell membranes,
and there's people on a really good diet trying to get their glucose levels down and they can't budge below 90.
You may know, I've dealt with diabetes patients in the past, when they come to me and their glucose levels are 240,
and they could go on a perfect ketogenic diet, they can't budge their glucose levels below 180.
They can't. It's just, they can't, they just can't, their cells are too damaged.
So, hopefully there wasn't too much to answer that question, but it's so...
Can I ask a follow-up question I can't tell from that.
So, free you, I had an integrative doctor that I was going to that arbitrarily just put me in that form,
and I've never had free diabetes or diabetes, and I don't believe I have it now,
and I'm not above 100 with the glucose monitor thing.
I was going to keep taking it just to help, but I think the oncologist said that I can do whatever I want,
and that's his recommendation to get off, because your body starts to get reliant on it,
and then it, then it really loses its effectiveness, which you're opinion about, in a form in any way.
You know, I don't, I met for a bit is a drug that is used for diabetes patients to get their glucose levels down.
That's the first go-to drug in a newly diabetic patient, newly diagnosed diabetic patient,
and it works pretty well.
So, the idea is, well why don't we just put cancer patients on metformin to get their glucose levels down?
Well, if you do that without changing their diet, you're not really ultimately helping the person,
but let's say you're talking about diet, you're trying to get them on a low sugar diet,
and we're going to use metformin.
I don't see any problem with that.
Is there a possibility that metformin is going to stop working because your body gets used to that?
Well, yes, there is.
Is that necessarily a bad thing?
I mean, it's like stopping using it, I guess.
So, I guess I wouldn't be opposed to any cancer patient using metformin as well.
The only negative is that it's a drug.
It has negative effects, and it can have negative effects on one's liver.
So, again, just like that other question, should I use medication or should I try to do an herbal approach?
I just think it's always best to not use drugs if possible.
But for a person who can't get their blood sugar level down, that can be another support.
But it can be a crutch for some people to think that they can just eat a bad diet.
So, you have to be careful of that, too.